all right
i am ready
for some speed running
we are
53 points away from the conclusion of
the speed run
let's cut into that
and let's play
[Music]
i want to try to play more in a bow
constrictor okay 2182 very very strong
opponent
and um
well let's play let's play sicilian
let's see uh how accelerated dragon will
hold up at this level
if you guys remember in the five minute
speed run i played almost exclusively
the accelerated dragon
and i want to see how it holds up at
this level
let's see whether people have found the
reputation bishop p2 okay so this is a
peaceful line
um it's not particularly bad but it
allows black to equalize
there is a very specific reason why
white usually puts the bishop on c4 in
the accelerated and it's to stop me from
playing d5 here we
essentially exploit the drawback of that
move by playing d5
and generally in the accelerated if you
can play d5 in a good you know in a good
version
then you solve all of your opening
problems black breaks through all our
pieces are active
black is equal here
now white is not worse if white plays
accurately but
if white's not accurate he can end up
being worse here
yeah this is this is well known theory
knight 65
knight 66 bc
okay now bishop d4 i think is one move
and it's equal yeah this is josh so
we're going to have to manufacture
winning chances here
we should do four
so there's a couple of options here
as far as i remember um
if i'm remembering my theory right
let me try to remember actually
so one option is to play knight take c3
and force white to take with a pawn
and ruin white's queen side bond
structure but then both of our pawn
structures are going to be ruined
um
but i think that a more
circumspect option
is to do something very unexpected i
mean you guys are not expecting me to
say this it's something see at this
level some of this stuff you kind of
just have to know so what i'm about to
do is a great example of a line which i
remember seeing somewhere but i probably
wouldn't have even been able to figure
it out myself um if
if i didn't know about it
or actually wait take sticks so the idea
is to play bishop takes d4 queen takes
d4 and then queen b6
and essentially try to force a queen
trade on my term so i can correct my
pawn structure
i mean that may lead to a draw to a
bunch of trades in a draw though that's
the drop back
yeah so you know maybe we can actually
play knight take c3 because this creates
a little bit more imbalance in the
position and it's a simpler move so
i'm going to say bishop takes d4 for
later let's play knight takes c3 okay
bishop takes e3
okay so he also wants to trade bishops
that's fine with me
that's fine by me
obviously we need to take that bishop in
order to
ruin a white spawn structure
okay and this is not a good move because
he's giving us the d file he's playing
for a draw
okay now let's try to devise a strategy
by which we're going to play for a win
in the same game
a couple of moves immediately come to
mind um the first move i'm sure you guys
probably are tempted by this move is
rook to d2
but rook td2 is not as effective as it
looks i think because of bishop d3 and
then the rook is kind of trapped there
so instead i think we should go for the
second tempting move which is bishop f5
developing with tempo
why not right hitting the pawn on c2
and what may happen is we get some
position upon up
okay now
the key question is should we take on c2
or should we make some other move
should we should we take on c2 here
so
we need to calculate um and it's quite
easy to calculate bishop takes c2 bishop
takes c6 and then rook a to c8 skewering
the bishop in the pawn we absolutely
should take there is no reason not to
another byproduct of taking on c2 is
that he can't put a rook on b1 anymore
and he can't put a rook on d1 anymore
either so that bishop is actually
extremely good and
if he goes rook c1 i think he might go
rook fc one there's rook f e1
we we want to protect that bishop at all
costs unless he chases it away in the
right way
okay so obviously here we should play e6
and protect the pawn
we could have also gone king f8 i don't
know
maybe maybe king f8 was marginally
better it doesn't really matter
well rook t2 would be premature because
our e7 pawn was hanging
right our pawn was hanging so we do need
to defend the spawn
[Music]
well i don't know why we would play rook
ac8 here when we can just ignore this
pawn and take black white spawn there's
no point in defending c6 it's already
defended indirectly
with this idea okay c8 and then rook
takes c3
and we're going to be upon up in the end
game
yeah so many dark square weaknesses and
so many pieces that he can exploit them
with
okay so we're going to take on c3
against every move except bishop e4 then
we're going to take the bishop first
okay so
in such positions at this level you
never want to play a move automatically
right you always want to be aware
of
you know various inter mezzos and maybe
we want to go rook c7 first
in this particular instance i don't
really see the point of going rook c7
first
but in general you have to be aware of
such intermediate moves don't ever take
a piece automatically
okay so this is his big big idea this is
his big idea he is trying to create a
pin against our rook
and then he's going to try to pick this
bishop off by playing probably rookie 2
and bishop before it center so here we
need to think logically and find a way
to extricate this bishop but to
extricate this bishop what does that
mean that probably means finding a way
to reinforce the rook on c3 the real
problem here isn't the bishop it's the
fact that the rook on c3 is undefended
if it was defended we would be able to
move the bishop wherever we wanted
so how do we what is the most efficient
and the safest way of defending that
bishop it's to play rook to d7 thank you
don't swat swarming please and jeff
gross poker with a raid already of 60
thank you rook d uh d7 to c7 yeah
i actually think that's even better than
rook d2
because
what is the issue with the rook d2 the
issue of rook t2 is that it doesn't
actually protect the rook on c3 i think
it is safer to play rook d7 and then
rook c7 and then we will for sure be
able to move our bishop does that make
sense
rook d2 is also a great move maybe even
objectively rook d2 is better but i
don't want to deal with a headache
of this rook being unprotected
thank you jeff appreciate it
i hope i'm making sense
when you are trying to solve a pin or
take the sting out of a pin the best
thing to do is either to move the piece
that's pinned that's not an option here
the second best thing is to reinforce
the piece that's been thank you dot dot
slash four for the prime
well bishop before dc7 that's the whole
point
you should see this that's the whole
that's the whole point of our last move
guys if you were following my logic you
would understand that
now we are defending the bishop with two
separate rooks
and white is in huge trouble
bishop f3 so that's a good move i think
he's at least trying to
keep pieces on the board
okay
so
let's figure out where we want to move
this bishop because we want to be as
accurate as possible so where do you
guys think
we should remove this bishop to
should we go this diagonal should we go
here
there is a certain logic i think to the
correct move here
you guys are
on top of your game bishop a4 exactly
i'm impressed and the idea here is to
stop the rook from coming to d1
we want to prevent our opponent from
occupying important open files this
bishop is also quite invulnerable if we
had gone to f5
yeah maybe he would have had some g4
ideas later we don't want to put the
bishop on a square where it can be
easily attacked
and if you have if you didn't get this
move don't worry just make sure you're
understanding the logic
now i want to make it clear that it's
not like bishop f5 is a terrible move
we're not talking here about big
mistakes we're talking about small
subtleties that together
form the basis for
really good endgame play
none of this is a life or death decision
not even rook dc-8
i hope that's clear
and you shouldn't think of this as like
i didn't see one move therefore i suck
this is pretty difficult stuff
truly it's not
easy to generate this kind of logic
okay
so take stakes i pre-moved rook takes c3
okay keep the questions for after the
game h3 now what should we do here
what should be the next
stage of our plan
next stage of our plan
should be to identify white's biggest
weakness and then immediately attack it
now there is an important subtlety here
there is rook c2 that's one way to
attack the pawn
but very often these frontal attacks are
even stronger rook to a3 in my opinion
is even better
why is rook a3 better than rook c2 well
there is a tactical component to this
and then a positional component the
positional component
is that attacking a pawn while
blockading it immobilizes the pawn if
you go rogue c2 he can go a3 and then
we're going to have to keep pursuing a
moving target
as you know pursuing a moving target is
harder
so
here we pursue a stationary target the
tactical
reasoning here is that rookie two
which would seem to be a pretty pretty
nice way to defend the plot actually
fails through the move bishop to d1
which i know a lot of you guys saw
winning at least a second pawn
and so if white goes rocket one
it's our turn to use a pin against
dwight we play bishop b3 we pick off the
second pawn and the rest is a matter of
pretty straightforward technique we just
start pushing our passer
rubenstein akiba rubenstein is really
one of the first people to i think show
this idea of
fronting upon and attacking it while
blockading it thank you dot slash four
for the 200 bits
yeah rubenstein had some very famous
games where he did this
particularly also against flasker
as he's thinking i'm going to try to
pull that game up
if you want to learn proper end game
play
you should definitely consider reviewing
rubenstein's games
what
yeah i found the game
so after we finish this game
i will show you the
rubenstein game where i
kind of really got inspired
uh where i kind of understood the
importance of blockading with a rook
okay rookie two and there comes bishop
d1 this is the crushing move
okay rookie rookie two then bishop
bishop d1 this is a skewer
if he goes rookie three then obviously
we trade everything and we're a pawn up
in a pawn end game that doesn't even
need to be calculated that's obviously
winning
but um you know
oh
my god
oh my god what
oh
oh my god
i cannot believe that that is a hundred
by montana
[Applause]
oh my god ridiculous
man is crazy
oh my god thank you montana you're
trying to make me lose on time here i
see what you're trying to do
i really appreciate that
the incredibly generous
at all times
thank you montana for the hundred
great stuff all right well we gotta win
this fun end game then i'm gonna thank
you properly so
one thing that a lot of players struggle
with in pawn end games is uh the
question of where to put the king where
should we go with the king and it
doesn't actually really matter
um we can go this way but there is i
think a much better pathway for the king
so one really good way of approaching
these kinds of end games is to start
by identifying your opponent's biggest
weaknesses so
really take a deep dive into white's
pawn structure
now we see that this pawn on h3 is
actually isolated right
so because it's isolated the ideal
scenario is to find a way to tie down
white's king to the defense of that pawn
but in order to do that we have to get
our own king into a position where it's
contesting that pawn so the ideal square
is h4 if we can get our king to h4
white's king is going to have to stick
in the vicinity of g2 and h2 and then we
can slowly but surely advance our pawns
you don't need to rush
with any pawn moves but
he's not going to be able to do anything
about our eventual pawn pushes so the
first step is going to be trying to walk
the king as close as possible to h4 now
we're probably not going to get there
but that's okay we're going to get close
enough in order to tie down
we're going to get close enough to tie
down white's king permanently
king h6 we are not going toward the
center
all right so i know that the principle
dictates that we should go toward the
center
but this is an exception to the rule
here we have a very specific destination
i hope i explained that clearly
like the logic behind not going toward
the center but going rather toward the h
file
it's hard to see that square but if you
follow the logic of identifying isolated
and weak pawns
you know you'll know this idea
so
it's all about experience
this is all about experience
and now we sort of slowly but surely
advance all of our pawns
being very careful of a couple of things
what do we need to be very careful about
as we advance our pawns well
the first thing is not to position our
pawns in a way
where your opponent for example what
would be bad here is going g5 and e5
why would that be bad because white
would play e4 and then we would have a
very hard time pushing that f pawn right
we don't want to create a swiss cheese
situation where we can't make progress
despite our extra pawn
so the way that we want to start here i
think
is we don't need to play a5 i mean we
can even let white push a6 it doesn't
matter i don't think he's going to make
it all the way here
e5 is a great way to start f5 would be a
swiss cheese move because white would
play f4 and fix the e pawn not allow us
to play e5 of course we would still be
winning we'd be able to play g5 but i'm
trying to play as clinically as possible
here so e5 i think is the best way to
start
then we play f5 g5 etc
if he plays a5 we can play a6 just for
fun
we can play a6 just to deplete whites
pawn moves and force him essentially to
decide
all right so we're winning here pretty
straightforwardly
okay so let's think about this for a
second
if we play e4
then white is going to go h4 and that's
just not something that we want to allow
we want to keep pawns on the board
let me think
yeah so let's go f6
let's hold the tension by playing f6
thank you for the hundred dots left fork
i will explain the problem with taking
after the game
but what we are trying to do is avoid a
situation where we trade off all of the
pawns except one pawn
i actually should have played a5 and i
will explain this also after the game
there's a lot of stuff to unpack in this
end game very instructive i think
all right so here
let me think take stakes g5
sticks
hmm this thing takes takes g5 takes
takes f5
six
four
six can you six takes at five five sixty
five c5 v6 there there there
takes takes g5 takes takes f5 g4
king f6 g3 king takes g5
takes takes g5
takes takes f5 g4
sticks and then 65 okay let's take
okay i'm running low on time but i'll
explain my calculations after the game
don't worry we're fine
everything is under control
i think but i might be wrong also
no but this is winning because now we
just walk over to the other side yeah
we just we just walk over we let him
take our pawn
and the point is we walk over and take
his pawn but he didn't go for the most
testing defense i will show you what i
was actually calculating
all right
very nice
i think my technique could have been a
lot better but it did the trick
okay
so
we're going to skip pretty quickly to
the end game here because i'm pretty
tired and
i want to focus on the important part
here
so bishop e2 is the old move and the
move d5 equalizes this is one of the
drawbacks by the way of the accelerated
is that
is that you often get these get these
liquidations by the way i forgot but in
this position you can also play knight
before this is a
viable alternative and this this leads
to less of a trading game so i probably
should have done this night before and
then taking the pawn like this
but okay i took takes takes bishop d4
knight c3 and i i think black is is
better here already
uh queen takes d8 is a mistake giving up
the d file for no reason thank you
venice he should have taken with bc but
you know we would have played bishop f5
or bishop e6 and
black is a very nice position
so takes takes bc bishop f and already
this is extremely nasty for white right
you guys can ask questions along the way
i know i'm going pretty fast so far
okay bishop f3 bishop takes c2 so just
to clarify
bishop takes c6 there's rook ac8 i think
a lot of people thought
that white could play rook c1
force our bishop back and then take on
c6 but that misses an important point
what should black
what should black do here
oh first of all there's bishop a4 bob
mcgowan very
nice bob mcgowan you definitely deserve
a sub for that
but uh i was planning rook d2 which i
think is even stronger because it
defends the bishop
and after bishop c6 we still have rook
c8
um we still have brooks c8 i'll give you
a sub
so rook fe1 e6
bishop c6 or kc and i mean he didn't
defend the best so he shouldn't have
taken this pawn
but obviously such positions are very
hard to defend so rook d7 is an
important point
rook d7 is an important point
all right um
so
in this position we need to protect the
stroke so we play rft7
bishop b4 and rook d c7
bishop f3 and now bishop a4 to cover the
d1 square take stakes h3 now let me do
the first detour
how did i know to play rook uh rook and
then like where did i learn to do this
well
the inspiration for this was a
rubinstein game that i remember very
clearly it was one of the
more inspiring games that i looked at
rubenstein against emmanuel lesker
so
you guys can kind of sense the
similarity between my game and this game
both feature this weak pawn on a5 on a7
so what does ruben stein play here the
first move is forced because his a pawn
is hanging
so the first thing is and also ruben
sign sinus up upon
there's a lot of similarities here so he
goes for k5
after rook b7 he plays a very
instructive move
and he plays it for a different reason
than i played it but it's still very
instructive
it's still very instructive uh rook a6
yeah
what is rubenstein's idea well first of
all he's fixing the pawn
second of all he is cutting off the king
this is an important concept in the end
game laterally cutting off the king not
letting it get to the center
and now rubenstein starts very patiently
pushing his pawns e4 h4 to grab some
space
g4 bring the king up and he just grabs
space on the king's side
brings the king up brings the pawn up
he repeats moves to gain time
and now a3 very patient play
and alaska resigned because the game was
adjourned and this actually leads to
zugzwang for black
the idea of a3 was also to cover the b4
square
no matter where black plays either white
plays e6 or
after king f8
white infiltrates with king g6
if black plays rookie 7 then white plays
e6 check and the reason rubenstein
didn't go e6 here is because of king e7
blockading the pawn thank you radcliffe
for the 11 months do you guys see what
i'm saying he has to wait for black to
occupy that square with his rook
now e6 is much stronger you force the
king to h7 and then you bring the rook
to d7 the rest is easy and alaska
resigned
so that's how easy it is and it's all
because of that rook on the sixth rank
um i know i went quickly through this
game but i think you guys get the point
this idea is kind of important
it's a rook a3
well i say damn girl even if it's a boy
so
oh you mean inversion yeah no it's
always damn girl
damn boy doesn't roll off the tongue
like that
um
okay
so rook a1
and it would have been met with the move
bishop b3 followed by bishop takes or
rook takes
a2 understood and then we're up two
pawns and the win is easy
so rookie two bishop d1 let's transition
to the pawn end game so king g7 king h6
king h5
okay so
in this position i made what i think is
a slight mistake i think i should have
played a5
now if you guys want you know to extract
some lessons in the same game then
listen very carefully because this is an
important point i'm about to make
it is better to fix this pawn
as
deeply into white's territory as
possible so let me give you an example
of why this situation is a lot worse for
black than this situation and it's not
because it's not because white's king is
going to go all the way over here that's
not really a risk because he's not going
to make it
but watch what happens let's say we
follow the game continuation e5
um white plays f4
and let's say for a second that we
decide to play this very simply we just
trade all the pawns
how could this go wrong for black well
imagine a situation
like this king h3
we think we're winning we go g5
everything is great but wait a second if
we took away the apons this would be a
draw right because the pawn is on the
same file as the king
but very often these positions are
winning because we use the pawn as a
decoy
and we walk the king over take the pawn
and then promote the pawn in the time
that white takes to take our pawn
but do you guys see why why now why it's
bad that this pawn is on a6
because
because the problem here is that
we have to walk over to our side of the
territory and in the time that we spend
taking the pawn white's king has time to
go back
to the ideal square
but let's compare even this situation
let's shift the pawns off to like a3 and
a4 that would already be winning
right if we
have the exact same situation
let's imagine for for a second that
our pawn
was on a three
and now we're gonna make the exact same
moves the exact same moves
this is already winning because
we don't have to walk back toward our
side of the board we walk straight to b2
and white does not make it so
the lesson is that if you're
anticipating an endgame like this it is
best to fix your opponent's pawn as
close as possible to his territory if
practicable
which is what i didn't do here i kind of
forgot about that and i allowed him to
push respond a5 which didn't spoil
anything but made it a little bit
tougher to win
so f4 f6
all right keeping as many pawns on the
board as possible
now you might ask what was i actually
calculating here
um i was calculating a very specific
line so after he takes f4 he takes f4 g5
isn't this a draw well no because i keep
my pawn as far away as possible from his
king
that is why it is actually
counterproductive to push your pawns
before trading all of them because we
want our pawn as far away as possible
why because we want it to take as long
as possible for white's king to walk up
and take the pawn does that make sense
we don't want the h font to be on h4
right now because then it would only
take one tempo for white to capture it
right see that's why you gotta be so
careful what was i calculating i was
calculating the move f5
which actually leads to a very
interesting endgame because if we try to
walk our king out like this
actually this is a draw look at this
position king g4 and black isn't zug's
bag and has to give up the g5 pawn this
is a drop
so can anybody tell me what black should
do here
i'll give you guys 30 seconds to think
about it what black is an only winning
move here as i just checked with the
engine
you have to play g4
but what if white plays king f4 how
should black proceed here
this is where
the beauty comes this is what i had to
see
now we play g3
and we distract white's king we go king
g5 and we're winning the second line
after f6
i had to make sure
that white is not able to take the pawn
and walk the king back in time and it's
actually really close so watch
it's actually close
it's literally if white had one more
tempo he would get it to c2 and it would
be a draw but here we we take the
opposition
and we push the pawn so it's winning by
a single tempo i had to make sure of
that welcome to the uh hell of pawn end
games
so this was not forced i could have won
i could have won according to the engine
uh by playing
the move h6 and then g5 without trading
on f4 first
and the reason this is an easier win is
because the more pawns you add the less
important it is
for us to have the right positioning
with our passer because here we can win
simply by giving up the g pawn for the e
pawn
all right so that's not hard it's just
how did i do this calculation it's easy
to visualize these end games right the
less pieces there are the easier it is
to visualize so i'm not going to pretend
that this was
particularly impressive this is a pretty
standard calculation that you have to do
and i took a while doing it so in a
blitz game i would have trusted my my
calculation sooner but here i doubled
and triple checked it
all right um i think it's time for me to
call it today that basically concluded
the game he did not play in the most
testing way of course he played
he played ftxg5 which which is an
elementary win because now this pawn is
really really far away from the king
so if you're on the defending side of
these end games you have two main tips
thank you moman and gringo two main tips
for if you are on the defending side of
a pawn on game the first is if there's a
corner pawn push your pawn as far as
possible into your opponent's territory
it's counterintuitive because it sounds
like it's going to be easier for your
opponent to capture that but in reality
that gives your king more time to walk
back to your territory
the second tip is to try to lure your
opponent into pushing as many of their
pawns as possible which would mean that
your king has an easier time taking upon
if it becomes a decoy and then you can
also review on your own time the game
rubenstein last year saint petersburg
1909
for a very good introduction into these
kinds of
end game techniques in the rook end game
all right
all right guys great game thank you for
uh for thank you for being so engaged i
really appreciate it
uh it would be
yeah it would be a lot more lame if
people were not as engaged as they are
so i really appreciate it
i will raid
who will i raid
i will raid
let me see
one moment please sorry
um rosen is streaming
then i will write eric is he just i am
rosen
i will rate eric rosen
all right um i am rosen right okay all
right eric guys thank you for hanging
out if you would like more if you
haven't heard enough of my voice
tomorrow at 9am i will be streaming and
commentating on the chess.com channel
with robert hess so long
i'll see you guys
[Music]